one of the biggest additions to this
year's Madden is the new longshot story
mode the mode combines cinematics with
playable situations Madden fans are
accustomed to today we bring you the
first minutes of Devon Wade's journey to
the NFL both on and off the field
does this mode remind you of any other
story driven games like the Tell Tale
series discuss in the comments below and
be on the lookout for our Madden 18
review coming soon thanks for watching
[Music]
got the ball now some storms on the knee
time's running out on the first all
Texas Super Bowl time for just one play
okay lastly let's read slant reversed
then run over here okay dad get away you
worried about being a little broken down
man like me not to us okay
[Music]
boom cools rolls out wide Texas down by
five three detectives with the Cowboys
Devin wait at the line for the final
play of the game just walked in a mind
its biggest moment of your life
lady 652 Hut hike
[Music]
yes touchdown the cupboard when is Super
Bowl yeah oh my gosh
shake and bake baby boy
[Music]
[Music]
you can't go there
[Music]
[Applause]
Carrie don't you wake up the whole
freakin neighborhood yeah well there's
good man because I want everybody to
know that today is the day that we put
Malthus on the NFL map you keep honking
and yelling all over the place and they
didn't know whether we wanted to or not
okay it's Andy baby
Andy if we freaking make it imma be a I
took a lot of time we get to Dallas I
started to eat something oh I'm sorry
I'm sorry did you did you want to melt
your face off or did you want to keep
your Tootsie's warm or do you want to
actually be able to see out the
windshield actually be able to see other
ones you is that so I thought
[Music]
[Music]
I know picker truck range it
and poops and straw hat
just to climb past anymore
[Music]
ever since wave I can't find no to buy
in the side console
[Music]
who's gonna ride the subway
on the last cowboy
Colten crews here with my best friend
and superstar quarterback Devin Wade
we've been in the car for a while now
Devin how does it feel to know that in
just 21 hours we will be at the regional
combine and in just 33 hours we will be
signing contracts in the n-f-l yeah you
notice not how it works right yeah I
know okay super regional combine NFL
Draft boring details boring boring
boring details hey man you got his
winning a Super Bowl man we made it to
Memphis yet and there you have it folks
killjoy juego locked in and ready for
success
oh boy yo go hey said I get this on
camera too hey come on dude you know I
can't go when people are watching yeah
seriously
don't you dare do it don't you dare
[Music]
I'm gonna keep my hand come on man
deep don't do it
[Music]
[Music]
we
[Music]
yeehaw told you I'd get you here on time
hey Devin let's get this on my feet feel
it's not we made it to Indy just under
the wire I'm half expecting a call from
the Brickyard now you wouldn't need to
drive like a maniac you weren't taking
selfies with every proper Graceling man
come on man we had to stop there
you got a respect for [ __ ]
I respect getting to checking on top
coming to close down ten minutes pushing
in pushing someone's a worrywart
wait D let me get us together under this
banner before they take it down D come
on I got four whole people watching code
if we missed a sign in there I finally
made it in D for the regional combine
look out world
NFL take note I would knows we're saving
yeah let's go Hoku Oh got a heart
hey man man oh we're here oh sorry
Devin Wade and ko Cruz we closed down I
crossed y'all to offers no show I try to
be kidding me wait wait I told you we
should've hurry man excuse me miss I am
so sorry we're late
you see it's all my fault not knocking
to Empire zone told you we shouldn't
stop to Graceland oh did you say
Graceland yeah
do you like us do I like Elvis well
bless my soul what's wrong with us
shouldn't have got known the great slam
buzz but if we if you let us in the
carmine no give it free tickets when we
make the Superbowl uh-huh Joker's just
made my night thank you so much yes
thank you so much you're not gonna
regret this I promise you push I saw the
spoilers for this week's Empire you're
not missing a thing hey you know what
huh I'm gonna need these two oh dang man
oh you can have
[Music]
everything is falling down everyday and
everynight my god Hollywood
just happening
- interception is 3015
in the second half
[Applause]
[Music]
so what were you thinking
[Applause]
take a seat
[Applause]
ha it's the fits it fits yo D yeah man
yeah what do you say
my bet I was just saying that the stuff
it's perfect man I mean look at me dude
look good feel good I'm ready for
tomorrow you try to stuff on you know
but I'm good
all right you sure you good good good
okay because you know I need you right
tomorrow Maundy you got to be hooking me
up in front of those Scouts man I need
all the help I can get you know all eyes
on us baby
uh-oh Depot Depot Oh he tracks it oh
he's got it oh oh he stars oh yes sir
they made it all seriously what do you
think we go to the same team I won't go
to Denver man how about Miami Miami be
fine
I'm Ken Austin national director of the
regional and super regional combine
hello and welcome
I want to say right away that this is
world-class athletics gentlemen in five
years we've only had a hundred and fifty
six players out of 2,200 make it to the
NFL
that being said you have an opportunity
today to impress Scouts from all 32 NFL
teams to beat the odds come on
from this moment on you're being
evaluated
you know folks refer to you guys as long
shots
well I like shots
[Music]
right
[Music]
nice finally we do we came here for a
but alright listen up I know how
important today is to you we want you to
raise your draft grade grade some value
that you can use to shop yourselves to
NFL teams but you have to do your part
relax as much as you can and just do
your best
we're gonna start with a pocket movement
drill now pay attention I want you to
take a five step drop and I'm gonna give
you a direction to move in when I'm done
I'll yell ball I want you to throw it to
that receiver over there understand
[Music]
move
move move Oh
nice throw who's next
all right let's move on to the route
tree I want each of you to take a five
step drop and then throw the route that
your receiver will be running let's see
the first three guys throw weight you're
up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dang man do i I can't hold on to a thing
hey Kara you know maybe if you're
throwing to me I could make a play next
up I kiss was places come on Dee I need
this
excuse me bye hey do you mind if we swap
no it's cool
yeah thanks
you again is there some sort of problem
no sorry
you're the best Dean Thanks just make
sure you catch it
next up
[Music]
oh there you go
I told you you got this whoa shake and
bake baby
all right let's see if we can throw this
out nobody's been able to hit it all day
[Music]
[Music]
great work gentlemen now for some of you
this is the end of the line for others
we'll see you at the super regional
combine all the best
no death I thought that was you
I see you still get that cannon for an
arm
what up Mario heard you uh we're in the
middle east or something something like
that yeah you still got them happy feet
Happy Feet what are you talking about
man you sacked him like what once in
high school hey no disrespect meant I
get mad props to anyone give your boy
here full right come on - anyways I play
fast but them Scouts always talking
trash on my size you know what I'm
saying okay man what's your problem
let's get out of here come on man hey
add those drops early now he's saying
I'm too small I mean if he's thinking it
then the scouts definitely all know
listen to Mario he's an idiot
always has been I know but is he right
hey one plus one equals three baby you
know we've always been better together
yeah yeah Weezy okay okay I was going
[Music]